العمل. بينما يندلع اضراب من نوع
اخر في بريطانيا لا حركة
غذائية وذلك في تناقض واضح بين
المشهدين. فقد تحولت النعمة الى
اوكرانيا تأتي الصين لتسلب
الامريكان عقولهم. وكما يقولها
المستشفيات. والممرضون فقد فاض
بهم الكيل بسبب قلة الرواتب.
لادانتهم بالتعذيب والقتل العمد
لشاب جزائري يعود حكم الاعدام
انشاء حزام امني على طول حدودها
الجنوبية من الغرب الى الشرق في
استرداد مبلغ مائة واثنين
وثمانين مليار دينار عراقي نحو
والتطورات. بعد حكم القضاء
جزائري باعدام تسعة واربعين شخصا
مائة واربعة وعشرين مليون
وسبعمائة الف دولار امريكي كجزء
يريده العثمانيون ليعلن وزير
الدفاع التركي خلوصي اكار انه تم
الاسعار تجبر المتقاعدين في
بريطانيا على العودة الى سوق
وبعد ان تراشق الاسبان وتزحلقوا
على عصير الطماطم في حرب
من الاموال العراقية المنهوبة من
البلاد من قبل الفاسدين. ليعيد
الطماطم. ها هم اليوم في طوابير
طويلة للانتظار من اجل مساعدات
تحييد ثلاثمائة وستة وعشرين من
اعدائهم الاكراد حتى الان. ونفى
لاثارة الجدل مجددا وذلك بسبب
ايقاف السلطات الجزائرية لحكم
بينما هنا في ارض الرافدين اعلن
رئيس وزراء محمد شياع السوداني
الاعدام عموما منذ عام ثلاثة
وتسعين. ازمة المعيشة وغلاء
مستمرة لايام او قد تكون لاشهر.
اردوغان يؤكد ان بلاده تعمل على
اكار ان تكون قوات بلاده قد
استهدفت المدنيين في سوريا.
بذلك بصيصا من الامل. اذا فماذا
عن رصيد السيادة? الاحداث
الاكراد درسا حيث يتحضر الاتراك
لعملية برية في سوريا. فما الذي
اقرب وقت ممكن. كما بتلقين
المتحالفين مع اعدائها من
فتيل التصعيد شمال سوريا وتركيا
تنفي صلتها بالصواريخ ليتم
اعلام رسمية ولسان حال زعيم
كوريا يقول كل تلك الصواريخ التي
تركي وذلك حسب الاعلام الكردي.
فكيف سترد موسكو على اصدقائها
استهداف قافلة روسية كانت تنقل
عند لقوات النظام في الحسكة بقصف
شمال شرق سوريا دون وقوع اصابات.
ياتي ذلك عقب دعوة امريكية بنزع
الاتراك? لتقولها الحكومة
التركية. عملية مخلب السيف
اخافتكم ما هي الا بعض من
المقبلات فانتظروا الوجبة الدسمة
حساب. لكن مجنون كوريا الشمالية
لم يركم شيئا الى هذه اللحظة حسب
نقمة. بينما تستنزف روسيا مخازن
الاسلحة الامريكية بحربها في
ومع هذه المحببة الى قلب كيم
اعلنت بيونغيانغ ان هدفها
الباليستية هي وجبته اليومية
والمفضلة صار الغرب يحسبون له
مرافق اعتقال في اقليم شينجيانغ
واوصت بان تقدم الدولة للضحايا
الدول المحيطة، لكن هذه المرة
لامس القصف امريكا نفسها. وذلك
تعبيره. نعم. فها هو كيم جونج قد
حضر موقعا جديدا والتقط الصور
تشكل خطرا غير مقبول على الامن
القومي الامريكي وذلك بحسب
واسلحتها النووية. فاي قلق اصابت
به بكين خصومها. وخلال ذلك حثت
الاشخاص تزامنا مع تفشي فيروس
كورونا بشكل متفاقم في الاونة
قلقون من التعاون العسكري الصيني
الروسي. مضيفا ان الصين ليست
في مدينة يونج من اجل انشاء
معسكر للحجر الصحي يتسع لالاف
لاحقا. سوريا والعراق تتألمان
وتركيا تتكلم. حال العراق كحال
علاجات وتعويضات. فيالى قلوبكم
الرحيمة. بينما ينشغل الصينيون
عندما اعلن الجيش الامريكي عن
سقوط صاروخين على قاعدة امريكية
قراراتها القاطعة حيث حظرت لجنة
الاتصالات الاتحادية الامريكية
قد اصبحت سلاحا للتجسس. فبحسب
صحيفة بوليتكو هناك مخاوف
ولكن قد يكون من يتحكم به هي
المخابرات الصينية. المخاوف
جورنال. ليأتي الامين العام لحلف
الناتو يمس تولتنبرج ويصرح انهم
برفقة ابنته. هذه البنت الصغيرة
التي وصفتها صحف كوريا الشمالية
البيع والمتاجرة بمعدات شركتي
هواوي وزدتي هي الصينيتين لانها
الامريكية تتزايد بسبب الصين لكن
هذه المرة لم تتحمل واصدرت
للتصوير الاحترافي او حتى
للترفيه لكن اصحاب العيون الضيقة
لجنة تابعة للامم المتحدة. الصين
على اطلاق سراح المحتجزين في
عدوا لكنها تمثل تهديدا وهناك
قلق من انشطتها العسكرية
الاخيرة في الصين. كيم جونج يرعب
العالم. وبعد ان كانت الصواريخ
استخباراتية امريكية من استخدام
الاستخبارات الصينية لمسيرات
وتبقى الصين في طليعة الخصوم
للولايات المتحدة بل واكثر من
ايضا. شيطان الصين تزعج امريكا.
تتعدد الطرق وتختلف الوسائل
سوريا. فلا جديد يذكر ولا قديم
يعاد سوى ضربات وقصف مستمر من
بالغالية المحترمة بعد ان كان
الوصف في اول ظهور لها المحببة.
النهائي هو ان تصبح اكبر قوة
نووية في العالم وذلك بحسب وسائل
الترفيه كوسيلة للتجسس فعن اي
دعاء نتحدث فقد يذهب طفل ليلهو
هدايا هذا الطباخ. لتخرج الساخرة
الاولى في روسيا. ماريا زاخاروفا
والتي اطلقنا عليها لقب الخال
فرنسا فرع روسيا. فقد ردت معلقة
وبعد كل تلك الاستفزازات
الاوروبية حان الدور على الروس.
انهما سقطا في بولندا. قد يعلن
الناتو لاحقا عن من اوكرانيا
الولايات المتحدة على العالم
وذلك وفق قول الوزارة الروسية.
يخيفها. فهذه قد تكون طائرات
مسيرة مدنية وهي مجرد وسيلة
الاوروبي فقد جهز فأسا ثقيل
عليها اثار دماء مزيفة من الاسفل
بيولوجية لتحديث الجيش الامريكي
هذا البرنامج يضمن قيادة وسيطرة
لارسالها الى البرلمان الاوروبي
كهدية في علبة كمان. فما اغرب
الاتحاد الاوروبي. فهل بدأ
النزاع يتغلغل في عظام الوحدة
القومي الامريكي السابق جار في
اعداد وثيقة لانتاج اسلحة
لتكون البداية من طباخ بوتين حيث
ارسل هدية غريبة للاتحاد
لمواجهة فعلية? لكن الغضب
الاوروبي الاكبر كان من نصيب
تقدما من فئة فيرجينيا للهجوم
السريع. فهل يستعد الناتو
الامريكيين بجني ثروة من النزاع
في اوكرانيا بينما تعاني دول
على تصريحات بولندا باختفاء
صاروخ من الصاروخين الذين يفترض
الغربية لتعلنها الدفاع الروسي.
ان جون بولتون مستشار الامن
المتحدة. حيث غضب الزعماء
الاوروبيون بعد تأكدهم من ان
كروز لقلة مخزونها من الصواريخ
بعيدة المدى. فكيف سترد روسيا يا
امريكا كانت اكثر المستفيدين من
حرب روسيا واوكرانيا متهمين
الفين وواحد وعشرين باكمله من
بينها الغواصات الامريكية الاكثر
القوات الروسية تستبدل الرؤوس
النووية برؤوس حربية في صواريخ
وعشرين حتى الان خمس وثمانون
غواصة مقارنة بثلاث واربعين لعام
ترى? وهناك في الماء قبالة سواحل
بريطانيا. بعث الناتو برسائل الى
روسيا من خلال المواجهة الباردة
حيث شهدت خلال عام الفين واثنين
ان بلاده ستواصل دعم اوكرانيا
ماليا وعسكريا طالما كان ذلك
بعد تحذيرات متتالية من موسكو
بخصوص هذا الانضمام. الحرب تتأجج
يستفز الروس مصرحا ان روسيا يجب
ان لا تنتصر في هذه الحرب. مضيفا
روسيا ضربت اوكرانيا باسلحة كانت
مجهزة برؤوس نووية. مؤكدة ان
لسان الامين العام يقول الحلف
انه سيقدم المزيد ولن يتراجع.
تستمر الحرب الاستفزازية هنا
المستشار الالماني اولفشولز
الاطلسي اعلان من شأنه ان يغضب
الروس ويشعل فتيل العالمية وذلك
مشترك لدعم تحرك كييف للانضمام
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف شمال
ضروريا. لتنضم البريطانية الى خط
استفزاز الروس ايضا. باعلانها ان
اوكرانيا باجهزة تشويش للدفاع ضد
هجمات المسيارات الروسية. وعلى
وحلف الناتو يصب الزيت على
النار. باستعداده لتزويد
نعم فها هي الرئاسة الاوكرانية
تكشف عن اعلان بلجيكي اوكراني
الاعدام يعود لاثارة الجدل
واسبانيا تتصارع مع ازمة غذاء
الامريكان والروس هناك. فهل فعلت
قوات اردوغان وفي الجزائر حكم
حاد فما الذي يجري? اوروبا تغضب
روسيا. كلما ظننا ان الحرب
اقتربت من النهاية تظهر لنا
الايام ان ذلك ليس الا البداية.
قدما لمواجهة مباشرة مع روسيا.
وخلال حرب التصريحات الكلامية
مضيفا لن يكون هناك سلام دائم في
حال انتصرت روسيا. الناتو يسير
وتركيا تواصل حربها في العراق
وسوريا لتتساقط الصواريخ على
وامريكا تقطع وريد الصين الصناعي
بينما تنتصر الامم المتحدة
لمسلمي الصين فيال العجب وزعيم
كوريا الشمالية يعلن ساعة الصفر.
والذكاء الصيني يحول وسائل
الترفيه الى سلاح ضد واشنطن
تلعبان على اوتار صبر بوتين.
والقارة الاوروبية لامريكا. انتم
السبب انتم من ورطنا. طباخ بوتين
يرسل هدية للاتحاد الاوروبي
تغضب الروس بحيلة خبيثة قد تجرهم
لحرب عالمية. وبريطانيا وفرنسا
الناتو يعلنها. لن يكون هناك
سلام مع روسيا بعد اليوم. وكييف
لا تقعد.
العرب ضربتين في الراس توجع.